redonner un catalogue comme ça vous
regarde la maison les couleurs les
modèles s'intéresser aux clients être
attentionné avoir le sens du relationnel
des qualités indispensables pour
travailler dans le secteur du commerce
dans cette bijouterie de l'espace saint
quentin la connaissance des produits
peut s'acquérir avec le temps un gros
vendeur une bonne wendel prend du
plaisir à rencontrer l'autre je crois
mais personne via les fibres de vendeurs
et qui connaît pas le produit va
apprendre alors faut qu'elle apprenne
assez vite pour pouvoir être à l'aise
pouvoir performer pour pouvoir donner du
plaisir et en prendre dans son métier
vendre des montres des bijoux en or en
argent le quotidien des employés de
cette boutique une bijouterie
spécialisée aussi dans la réparation
alors tout va bien autre enseigne mais
même métier ce magasin d'accessoires
hommes et femmes
chapeau gants châle ou écharpe les
produits sont mises en valeur tout comme
le client même si la vente n'est pas
concrétisée
après tout les ventes ne se concrétise
pas parce qu'il ya des gens qui viennent
en repérage mais ça veut pas dire qu'ils
reviendront pas après
c'est le cas de ses deux clientes venus
en repérage il ya une semaine on a après
avec la capuche
c'est pas mal aussi et sinon j'ai avec
les manches finalement elles repartent
avec un plaid le gants assortis et un
châle les deux derniers articles
considérés comme des achats additionnels
nous en fait dans une tête faut
automatiquement qu'on sache quel
accessoire peut aller avec
au niveau des tons des couleurs pour
pouvoir proposer aux gens et quand ils
essayent en fait de leur montrer et de
leur présenter sur eux
un accessoire qui va avec avec 130
boutiques l'espace saint quentin emploie
près de 1800 personnes chaque année
environ 200 recrutements sont réalisés